[Music]
all right let's go to ryan in denver hey
ryan what's up brother
dr d it's good to talk to you how are
you sir good it's good to talk to you my
brother so what's up dude
well i kind of got a long-term problem
that
uh needs some help and needs some work
through um
three years ago i had my second child
he's uh
he has a disability
which causes him not to be able to walk
very well
i would say that he can get around on
flat hard surfaces but that's the limit
of his ability
and
as a kid myself i was super into sports
super into physical activities um
and my dad was right there with me and
going into our adult lives
we
we just kept it going i mean we
we've run marathons together we hike
mountains together we've remodeled our
houses like a good saturday afternoon is
ripping out the chainsaws and getting
after it like that is a good way to
spend time with my dad
and
and looking at my son
and looking at our relationship
i have
a deep-seated fear and i would even say
that it is into resentment that i will
not have that same experience with my
son
and
i don't know what fatherhood what like a
healthy father-son relationship looks
like
if it doesn't include all of these
physical things
um i
like i'm not afraid to learn that i'm
not afraid to understand what that means
and unpackage it
but
i'm i'm mad at the universe yeah that
we're in this situation
i'm really sad
i have some resentment i have some fear
and i i don't want that to poison our
relationship because he's a good kid
he's an awesome like dr d he's an
awesome kid he's an awesome kid
and i love the kid to pieces
but
but i don't know what the future looks
like with a kid like that
dude and a guy like me
i i i can't tell you
where did you learn that language
uh yeah i learned that from my father
okay dude
i'm saying like
your ability
to articulate how you feel
is
is reminiscent of someone who's done
some extensive counseling
or
has an extraordinary father
well we we've done both okay all right
all right okay
um
your ability to parse through i'm both
angry
and i here's where my anger is directed
and our future relationship was which is
a separate entity man it takes months to
get people to realize you're not mad at
her you're mad at what is right at the
relationship yeah that's so hard and
you're already there
that you can articulate anger and
resentment and sadness
dude you're way down the road i want to
tell you you're a brave guy
because here's why
most guys would not say out loud what
you just said
and they bottle that stuff up
and it poisons everyone including
themself and they die young
and they rob everybody of relationship
of safety of feeling loved and you're
not doing that
and you're maybe one of the more honest
people i've talked to in the last few
months and i'm grateful for you
it's awesome
now
you've said the right words
i don't get a sense that you have felt
them yet
no
not really i feel like if you felt them
it would be overwhelming in a way that
you might not that you don't feel like
you're ready for
yeah i i would say when i look at the
landscape of my life
i can see it over there
it's just over there yeah
but it's not right here yet
why not i would say like what are you
scared about honestly
so
the reason why it's not here is because
he's three and he's surrounded by
three-year-olds and his disability is
hidden by the fact that none of the kids
are super
super physical either
like nobody is running and jumping and
nobody like they run and they jump but
but it's close enough that it doesn't
look that different so it's not here yet
and he's got a younger sister and he's
still way more mobile than she is
but today when she surpasses him i think
is when it's going to really hit
and that's gonna be the big day
um so here's here's what you're doing
right now
you love that little boy
and you
can i be real hard is that cool
you remember
the way you used to look at boys like
that when you were a kid
yeah and you remember the way you and
your buddies made jokes about people i
was there too
until my very best friend on planet
earth
was in a life-altering car wreck and
he's unable to move most of his body now
and that was 25 years ago
and then i spent the last 20 years
working with people with all different
kinds of special needs whether they're
mobility challenges or able-bodied
challenges or
or cognitive challenges and it
re-changed my life but i had to go
through a serie a season of grieving who
i used to be
because i used to suck
because like you i thought every kid
should run fast and i was a high school
hero athlete and me and my dad played
you know what i mean
exactly exactly what you mean and so
you're gonna have to go through a period
of
forgiving yourself
and say i'm sorry
and then
the other thing you're doing is you love
this little boy so much you are
casting into the future
how bad his life might be and you're
trying to
trying to protect him from those things
you're going to rob yourself of
your current relationship always
anticipating future hurts let's be
honest kids are going to make fun of
them because kids suck they just do
yeah and
he's going to have periods of grief
where he wishes he could run and kick a
ball too
and that's going to suck
and
you all are going to find some things
that you all do together that no other
dad and son do
and you grew up with a dad who was hyper
intentional about loving you
demonstrably he showed you love he
didn't just talk about it
and i have every belief in my
every bone i have in my body that you're
gonna figure that out whether that
you're gonna be the greatest call of
duty dad of all time that game sucks
don't play that but what you're going to
be the greatest whatever guy of all time
or you're going to figure out how to
take him hunting with it some
cool there's some great opportunities to
there's all kinds of stuff you're going
to figure it out
but you got to get past your
self-forgiveness you got to get past
catastrophizing his future for him
and there's even probably a part of you
that's looked at one day you're going to
die and then who's going to be there to
protect him
yeah
and
have you already been there
been there done that okay yep the trust
fund is being funded as we speak there
you go
here's here's more important than your
money there's more important than your
money that's your turn
more important than your money
is you create a young man
who freaking
loves himself
who is scared of nothing
who is able to go that sucks and that
really hurts and i'm moving on
who learns the same words that you've
learned
i'm angry i'm resentful i am sad i'm
heartbroken
and then you make him bulletproof you
make him anti-fragile to quote to lab
you make him into somebody that when
people are on top of it like yeah just
keep doubting me dude keep doubting me
and watch what happens
i will write a program on this computer
code that will
that my my futuristic house will eat
your future i don't know what that's
going to look like in 100 years but you
know what i mean
you create a young man who is able to
face all challenges not who has every
challenge cleared ahead of him
and
you're just on a different path brother
and it's gonna be magical but it starts
with you looking in the mirror and
saying i'm sorry and
i'm gonna be the greatest dad this that
has ever existed
and i also want to back up for 30
seconds
dude we've been cast into this story
that family is supposed to look a
certain way
and some of that picture comes from what
we were born into right two and a half
kids and half of a dog and two cars two
suvs in a house right
like
if we don't have that
and it could be that our parents got
divorced or we have three sisters and
one brother whatever it looks like
there's a part of our brain that tries
to solve for that picture
and then the second complicating layer
is a story you were told you were told a
really beautiful story about what father
and son relationship looks like
it's ball games chainsaws fixing crap
talking crap
you know what it's it's it's
that's that's what father son is
so you've got these two pictures in your
head
and then you've got this beautiful
little boy with some different kind of
challenges he's gonna have some
different kind of awesomeness too but
he's got some challenges
and your brain is trying to solve for
those two pictures and i want you to own
those two pictures and i want you to
grieve the fact that they're not yours
and then dude your brain will go oh cool
looks like ryan's back in control i'm
gonna stop reacting and then you get to
solve for you get to you get to create
what the future looks like
is it is that ringing a bell with you
does that feel right no that that is
perfect you know sell for future
yeah dude solve it solve for freedom
solve for a future dude solve for more
laughter than you think your body can
handle
yeah i like that blend solve for a
future where your son
dude is able to make jokes faster than
anybody else at the table he's also able
to say
hey
that's parking spot is for me
and just so you know my buddy's a
paraplegic and we hassle him
dude to the point it is brutal and he
hassles us back
and it is yeah gnarly right
and i'll never forget the meeting and i
may have to i don't know if i've talked
about show i never forget when he was in
the hospital and we thought he was going
to die and then they said well he might
make it but if he makes it he's going to
have some
massive cognitive and mobility
challenges
and me and his little brother and one of
our other close friends chris we sat in
a in like a denny's or something in the
middle of the night while he we've been
sleeping on the floor in the icu for
several nights
and
we said hey
how are we gonna treat him
like are we gonna change everything up
and all of a sudden no
if he makes it out of this thing we're
gonna make fun of him like we always did
and he's gonna make fun of us and i want
you to know i'm telling you that because
of this
he's gonna have friends in his life that
will love him and razz him and protect
him because that's what friends do
and it's just gonna look different right
indifferent isn't broken different is it
wrong different it's just different
yeah all right so i threw a lot at you
feels different come back to me
yeah no that's uh that's a whole bunch
i'm gonna have to listen to this on the
podcast a couple of times because okay
i'm gonna be on packaging that for a
while but no i i
yeah i got a little bit of soul
forgiveness to do yes was i right there
i used to be was that right
yeah and i wouldn't say never i was
never mean and i was never cruel
but i was
i was a little you know
a bit of a turd i wasn't mean or cruel
either i maybe once or twice i was just
an idiot
but i was
that's exactly it i got a blind spot
that's it
after you said that i was like you know
what
we're going to have to spend some time
working through that because
i'm gonna have to grieve that part of me
and then i'm gonna have to forgive that
part of me yeah so that i can be a
better future for this little munchkin i
believe that that many of us millions
and millions of us know the world's
screwed up and we also know
i could
fill in the blank with any group you
want to
people with special needs people feel in
the blank
we know that we could treat different
groups of people better
or more right or we could say i'm sorry
but when we do that we have to look in
our rear view mirror that the wake of
people we've either hurt intentionally
or unknowing i didn't know that joke was
i didn't know that joke hurt like that i
was trying to be funny you know what i
mean i was a 14 year old kid i didn't i
didn't know i was 25 i didn't know
we have to look in our rearview mirror
at the wake of people we've run over
and say i'm so sorry
i'll start doing better today and i'm
like you i wasn't like just finding
students with special needs and being
ugly i just didn't notice
yeah and i just went through my life as
though
everyone should be 62 195 and be able to
run this fast i just it's called
privilege right it's called i didn't
know
and now i do
and now i make sure nobody
in my presence doesn't know that i love
them
and i think they're doing a great job
or uh like zach back there i could make
fun of zachariah
because that's incredible all right but
here i'm saying
yep now i'm not ever gonna but no i
learned and i'm gonna do better i'm
gonna forgive myself for what was and
i'm gonna go be about what is
and your son hear me say won
the
lottery with you as his dad
we're not sure about that yet no we're
not we're gonna we gotta we gotta we
gotta land that listen the fact that
you're even engaging this conversation
puts you in the rare rare air
top one percent of one percent
and then it's going to be about action
after this
yeah the action is the uh
we're going to be unpackaging that for
about a lifetime that's kind of i think
yeah
you're going to recognize oh this is i'm
projecting fear into the future here and
we're here right now
yeah yep i might have a heart attack and
he might have to figure out
how to get um an electronic wheelchair
and
that's a problem for future us
what i can do right now is put money
into that trust i can teach him how to
speak for himself and i can whip his
butt at minecraft i don't even know if
you whip somebody's butt at minecraft
i know mike tyson's punch out in super
mario brothers but
you hear what i'm saying
i do acknowledge it call it out the
stories you were born into the stories
you were told they're good stories and
they're fine but they're not reality and
now it's about living into that reality
god ryan you've
i i can't tell you i'm not just saying
blowing smoke at you
the fact that you're asking these
questions and articulating it in this
way
last little tip stay out of resentment
when you feel yourself in entering into
resentment
write a journal in fact you want to be a
super dad start a journal
and give it to him someday with that
that's the goal he's three right now
start a journal with here's how much i
love you here's how much i'm scared
about your future
i i'm gonna miss playing ball with you
but i'm gonna learn how to play the
cello or i'm gonna learn how to play
video games or i'm gonna learn how to do
do whatever you think is awesome
i'm gonna figure out a way for us to
play catch with football even though
you're not right i want you to keep a
journal on stuff one day you're gonna
give it to him
and he's going to have a
10-year 20-year 30-year 40-year arc
of just how much his dad loved him
i can think of
literally
no better gift
man